ah les questions kackert on les attend
bien sûr alors jean-luc je crois que ce
sont les dernières questions capter
avant celle que vous ferez pour le prime
spéciale du 2 juillet exactement donc
c'est pas les dernières
langage courant c'est les
avant-dernières oui et épuisante et on
voulait dire sa dernière dans la
quotidienne
voilà ce moment là ils essaient toujours
de me sauver mais c'est ça si alors
est-ce qu'on va on va expliquer ce qui
se passe il écoute tout il voit tout il
reprend tout ce que tourner les caméras
pendant les pubs et jean luc lemoine y
voit des choses qu'on ne voit pas et
forcément on découvre votre véritable
personnalité grâce à son look pas que
oui ça oui ah oui allez vous invite au
monde avec la question bonjour je
m'appelle monique la dernière fois vous
n'avez pas montrer le dossier
compromettant de cyril hanouna haut
est ce par respect pour lui ou juste
parce que vous êtes une petite couche du
mall c'est une très bonne question que
vous posez l'achat monique peut-on se
servir d'un de mes testicules comme
d'une balle anti stress et bien au
risque de vous décevoir non
ce soir c'est sans doute ma dernière
émission puisque j'ai décidé de vous
montrer à la fin de la rubrique ce que
cyril a réussi à éviter la dernière fois
non mais non peut pas là pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas vu les dernières carrière
un rappel des faits nous étions pendant
un coming next possible et pas dans les
quartiers attention est ce là tu le
gardes si l'adresse est là c'est pour
toi
qu'est-ce qui a pu mettre tous ces gens
dans cet état là qu'est ce que peut bien
avoir cyril à cacher vous serez à la fin
de cet embryon non si pardon je vous
laisserai une chance à merci y est chaud
alors sauf s'ils augmentent beaucoup
déjà 1 l'année prochaine peut que vous
avez pas le voir qui va bon sachez juste
que c'est par hasard que ce soit passé
pour un comics car pendant cette
émission parallèle où les chroniqueurs
sourit bêtement en arrière plan pendant
10 minutes c'est il se livre comme
jamais pour notre plus grand bonheur
ils font l'armure et nous en dit plus
sur sa vie tumultueuse et ainsi sa
légende s'enrichit chaque jour d'un
nouvel épisode
raconter janvier les rondes après
montrent ici pour un tire-fesses jeunes
est monté à 3800 mètres s'agit machine
sapphire est tirée terrils j'ai vu les
gars partir on va faire
et sombre affaire vous remarquez au
passage que plus rien et 1d n'aura lui
dès qu'on fait du tir fait 510 différent
oui d'accord pourquoi pas c'est vrai que
c'est assez courant alors il faut dire
qu'en cette fin de saison on soignera
résigné avec cyril que comme si elle
avait compris une bonne fois pour toutes
qu'il aurait jamais une conversation
cohérente avec lui j'ai vu civile
j'ai eu beau marc question tu l'a croisé
ce qui m'a dit tu te fais un v6 froide
et randy
à la paix une dette elle a fait la tête
de la prof qui aidèrent d'après l'invs
je ne ferai rien de ce bertrand cher que
ça c'est sûr et certain n'en faut que
l'année se termine là tout le monde est
fatigué même jean-michel à le bas lors
des dernières quatre heures vous avez
montré ses encouragements pour julien
combes et gym tous il en appelait là
c'est arrivé ça peut aller puis c'est
vrai que julien et moi on est
pratiquement jumeaux la méprise et
compréhensible la semaine dernière nous
recevions aurait le compte
ce n'est pas un mec c'était c'était pas
prévu mais que j'eusse commence à me
faire un peu de souci on va faire une
petite pause dans les quatre tiers alors
s'il te plaît est ce que tu peux venir
la ligne du haut enfin jean michel venu
ok non mais je m'inquiète vraiment elle
est la ville jean michel part en sucette
ou alors il n'a aucun sens des
ressemblances
ce qui est aussi possible car en début
d'année je vous l'avais jamais montré
mais il disait ça il ya quelques années
de monde les gens sont des lâches
moyenne relève et c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable regardez regardez jean michel
maire s'est assis mais pas ça la semaine
dernière il y avait le prime spéciale
aventure où mes camarades se sont
surpassés taille pour divertir jean
michel hécart milla rien foutu et
l'arrière tout dessus pour toutes les
missions mais il a tout commenter tout
de suite le débrief du bon camarade
on va vous amener dans un endroit que
vous ne connaissez pas dans lequel vous
n'avez jamais été prouvée régime
on peux pas vous dire de quoi il s'agit
l'orée de l'automne
j'aurais que la police ait novembre
julien courbet rien fait au nom
et au bout landes
ils descendront pas il en est descendant
potes ils n'ont pas peur de vous on sait
qui on est
et ça fait du bien d'avoir des amis dans
l'équipe n'avait quand on ne sait
apparemment vous inquiétez pas il ya un
prime le 2 juillet il va morfler je vais
m'occuper de lui la dernière fois je
vous avais montré la tête d'isabelle
pendant limitation de bertrand rappelez
vous bah oui
moi j'en ai pourquoi il fait le team est
un animal c'est allé beaucoup plus
terrifiante fatigue oui c'est comme à
l'école des fans s'est elle chante avec
emma bonne nouvelle bertrand a refait
d'imitation l'aespa
ça marche à tous les coups jean-michel
s'est fait mal à la main j'ai fait mais
je crois que c'était parce qu elle est
comblée ses mets préférés de il s'est
fait mal à la main mais il a mis une
seconde avant de se rendre compte
mais sa part la puissance il ya trois
semaines il ya trois semaines nous
recevions les finalistes de the voice et
notamment la très jolie batista et sa
voix envoûtante et j'ai signé sur
universal donc s'asseoir le 1er juin ça
s'appelle les champs liberté
rigole bien sûr c'est très bien même je
devrais te rappelles non mais c'est
formidable et nuit vraiment tout il
n'est pas des personnes seules mais il
ne pense pas parce que c'est l'émotion
de rencontrer des grandes voix d'
d'ailleurs savez vous comment on
différencie un chanteur professionnel
d'un amateur non et bien simplement sa
joie de participer à un karaoké
wade est allé à la bombe
les ragas en folie voilà le vent de la
quinzaine vous voulez je vous montre ah
oui je voulais pas monter parce que bon
il est pas bien grave mais mais bon
on adore alors par endettés j'étais
obligé le diffuser car vous pensez bien
que mes camarades quand ils ont vu ça
ils sont précipités non on va surtout
isabelle et n'aura elle est là rien vu
mais à la sortie qui s'est passé quelque
chose
donc elle va imaginer un truc improbable
et comme je sais pas coulé répondre
pardon maman
michel michel mathieu vistot boîte de
l'excusé bien entendu mais voilà la bcr
fin d'année les paviens michel je
t'embrasse très fort en version chambre
à sa famille faillible n a pas eu
d'accident pour moi oui on va quand même
si j'aime beaucoup et n'aura pas bon
amical à part ça une nouvelle fois syrie
nous avait brillé que sa créativité
on ne savait pas mais aussi mime or
regardez j'ai mon père j'ai eu besoin de
quelque chose c'est quoi les couilles
palais ni ben voilà c'est parti
parce que la famille de michel hervé
aussi des écrits pendant les pubs et
nora s'est adonné à son activité
favorite
à tort
j'adore tout simplement s'adorent voilà
la chronique est bientôt terminée c'est
la fin de l'année et j'ai décidé d'être
gentille que mes camarades merci je vous
ai souvent montré des conversations
entre jean michel et thierry mais vous
les connaissez vous connaissez leur
logique on va faire un jeu d'accord je
vous montre un début de dialogue entre
eux si vous réussissez à le compléter
je vous fais une promesse je ne
montrerai aucun dossier trop hard lors
des prochaines cas tiers qui seront les
dernières de la saison
si vous n'y arrivez pas jeudi stocks
tout au destin alors pour vous donner
une idée de ce que j'en réserve je peux
vous donner un exemple exemple par
exemple comment réagit et nora quand
cyril a fait appeler pour le coming next
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent 14
ces sommes voilà un autre exemple
ah oui pourrait sortir grave
alors lorsque gab le dis devant moi lors
des dernières khatir j'avais montré les
réactions de bertrand qu'on est assis à
côté de françois viot un plus connus sur
steam d'heure sous le nom de mich mois à
mèche et bien moi mèche a vu la rubrique
mais ça va il l'a bien pris
m
je la sens bien cette fin de saison
alors chef des titans
ah là là et c'est ce genre d'image que
vous allez savoir si vous répondez pas
la question mais on veut vous alors
alors vous êtes prêt pour jouer oui
alors évidemment jean michel est ici
peuvent pas jouer mais vous cyril 1 vous
pouvez j'ai pas été trop dur c'est
vraiment un classique de leurs échanges
ce jour là comme par hasard jean michel
avait repéré une fille d'un public tout
de suite le clip de do
j
gelli
ça se perd la queue de cheval une jolie
fille ça se perd les queues de cheval
qu'est-ce qui va se raconter juste après
chacun devant une proposition qu'il
aimerait bien être son palefrenier un
truc comme ça il y avait fait preuve
dans ton cul merci à la montée gilles la
mienne et les plus grosses qu'un cheval
a pas mal non je n'en voulais pas est ce
que vous vous en souvenez tous les deux
même pas c'est ça qui est terrible
dirigiste contexte début il ya une jolie
fille et d'un seul coup il se rend
compte que de cheval alors elle va en
voir une de queue de cheval
ouais cheval j'aimerais bien la sauter
un euro moi aussi j'en ai une chouette
je rappelle la dernière phase et ça se
perd les queues de cheval je dis moi je
pense qu'il a dit a pas moi bien sûr
il rappelle que ça va définir la
position du curseur pour les dernières
4/3
je le vois bien dire ça vous vous en
souvenez tous les deux la réponse en
images
lyon
un rêve de revenir
non mais
gta iii on peut le dire pourtant et
pourtant simple jolie fille queue de
cheval boeuf bourguignon
j'aimerais pas jouer à pyramide avec eux
comme pour tout qu'est-ce que vous avez
un gros déstockage pour la dernière ici
bon ça ça va être du goût est d'ailleurs
sorti encore et encore pas de destockage
on fait quoi de votre dossier comment ça
peut se passer alors j'ai fait du sport
un petit jeu ring pour vous chers même
principe
si vous complétez l'extrait je montre
pas le dos vous êtes seul à jouer alors
est ce qu'on peut voir l'extrait dans un
instant oui bien sûr on va se retrouver
dans un instant sur d8 avec jean luc
lemoine je vais essayer de me sauver
c'est la deuxième chez exact je dois
essayer de sauver ma tête si vous étiez
avec nous juste avant la pub jean luc
lemoine va me mettre devant mes
responsabilités exactement la semaine
arrière enfin il ya trois semaines
vous avez échappé au dossier on va voir
bon je vous laisse une chance j'ai sport
un petit jogging pour vous donc si vous
complétez extrait je montre pas le
dossier l'accord d'accord vous êtes seul
à jouer jean-michel parler des qualités
de comédien de thierry moreau
ben ali quel argument massue jean-michel
at il avancé pour dissuader thierry de
faire l'acteur et que va lui répondre
thierry peut-être qu'il va lui dire pour
te dire tu est même meilleur humoriste
carte d'acteurs des meilleurs humoristes
car qu'acteur peut-être évoluer l'année
vous l'a dit non non non mais c'est pas
ça du tout je le connais par coeur
celui-ci fait 20 ans que je connais la
réponse en images
il me met la pression
merci
des tickets et l'autre non maintenant
quand même accepté est pas cyril quant à
grasse alors bon ben là je crois qu'on
est obligé l'ordre sans rigoler voilà un
dossier non je ne devais pas montré non
c'est dans la boîte
c'est qu'au bout de trois ans dit mais
c'était du off
c'est ma reprise c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui oui la mine sur sa route
d'or qui sont comme vous voulez interdir
keith hallett dans les questions olala
comme bonjour je m'appelle mildred quand
je vois gilles verdez à l'étranger de
papillons dans le ventre alors que quand
je vois jean michel maire
j'ai des remontées gastriques est ce que
c'est normal